Big News. This is the point in the week. And
in the show where I mentioned some interesting
discussions from the David Pakman show, sub
Reddit, which you can find@davidpakman.com
slash r e d d I. T the first uh, thing I want
to mention from the subreddit is that the
subreddit itself has achieved more than 10,000
subscribers.
And in fact it's 10,098 as of this exact moment
when I am mentioning it. Um, yes, the sub
reddit has 10,000 subscribers, one of the
biggest sub reddits of independent progressive
shows. And there's really great discussion
there. There's a lot of topics suggested for
the show on the sub reddit. We have now a
full slate of moderators who ensure that um,
there is respectful debate and we limit trolling
and all of that stuff. So more than 10,000
of you are participating, uh, police keep
signing up. It's free and it's a really great
place to engage with other viewers of the
show and with the show staff, et Cetera, et
cetera. David pakman.com/reddit also, there's
a very interesting post on the sub reddit.
We mentioned, I believe it was last week or
the week before on audience questions. I was
asked, David, why is your show disproportionately
male in terms of its audience?
And I explained it's not just our show, it's
all online news and politics shows or this
is something that we contend with. We have
disproportionately male audiences and a post
was made, um, exploring ideas for attracting
more women viewers to the show and they range
from the wacky like doing the show with no
shirt on or possibly popping my color or speaking
Spanish. Um, or there are also others sort
of more reasonable ideas that were suggested
including a topic choice. Um, and other things.
And, yeah, I mean, I think that the, this
is actually, it would be an interesting nut
to crack because both from the point of view
of I would love to have more women in the
audience simply because, uh, I think that
that would, in terms of the feedback that
we get, provide more balanced feedback since
the, since the audience is disproportionately
male, the feedback that I get about the show
comes disproportionately from a male audience,
even though half the country is women.
So that would be interesting first and foremost.
And then secondly, from an advertising perspective,
we deal with a lot of advertisers who don't
want to advertise because they say, well,
your audience, you know, we target women,
or we at least need something closer to a
50, 50 audience based on our demographic research
in our focus groups. Your mostly male audience
is not a good fit. So I think financially
it would also be great for the show to attract
more women. So for all reasons, uh, that's
something that I think we should strive to
do. And you can comment on this by joining
the sub reddit@davidpakman.com slash reddit
now let me also mention I have something to
give away. I have a really great card game
to give away. Okay. This is a new sponsor
that is doing some ads on our show. Uh, the
game is called impeach the cards slap game.
It's a really fun game. It's great for parties.
I've played it with some friends. It's a combination
of really great humor about the Trump administration
and really great cartoon artwork. And it's
also just a fun well designed game and I have
five of these to give away. Okay. I have five.
I will send these to you. One of them, not
all, five to the first five people who email
meDavid@davidpakman.com or use the contact
form on our website. Okay. If you don't email
me in time and it'll just be the first, first
come first serve, we will send them anywhere
in the world. Email me. Say I want one of
the impeach card games. Include your address,
include all the information I need so that
that way we don't have to email back and get
engaged in this sort of endless loop of emails.
Okay. Um, but I've got five of those to give
away.
And if you don't get one of the five, you
can go to David pakman.com/impeach um, and
use the coupon code pacman to get 10% off
the card game and they've got a bunch of other
funny Trump's satirical tee shirts and other
stuff. David pakman.com/impeach to get 10%
off with the coupon code pacman. But I've
got five free impeached card games, great
for parties, especially if you've got conservative
friends coming over. Nice little game to pull
out instead of playing, uh, you know, anyone
of those other games, which I won't name because
they haven't advertised on the show.